let's go let's go let's go left go how
you feeling how you livin how you doing
what up homies awesome awesome awesome
show coming your way today so thank you
for sticking around cuz it's only gonna
continue to get better I'm gonna talk to
you guys for a little bit then David
deal two-time Super Bowl winner played
in the NFL for over a decade and he's
done announcing and broadcasting and all
that go to beyond here for about like 55
minutes to an hour I talked too much I
never keep time and then at the very end
yes we're calling Phil Simms at home I
checked with him I did not clear it with
Chris because Phil is a grown-up and
he's an adult and I'd like to hear from
him I want to go through a few things
with you one shout out to Andrew Mitch
aka would master 5,000 he says that he
will take off his eyebrows so eyebrow
gate will continue my advice to you
Andrew is I've decided I if possible a
waxing is really what I'd like and the
reason is because Blake jar wooden
didn't get thirty five catches if
there's any way to wax and then mail
them to me I would like to get them
framed for the studio for the YouTube
crowd out there I'd like for them to see
your eyebrows super excited about that
also do you check out the left Co PR
that's been working lately Robbie Gould
said he wants to play for the Bears they
gets franchise tagged by the Niners
super smart move also how about the NFL
players right now putting basketball
highlights out there
Derwin James Duncan Myles Garrett
tomahawk windmill I like what these guys
are doing dear players at the combine
more basketball video please
however we asked for your help with
names for this show what its gonna be
since Sims and Lefko is our IP we had
over thirteen hundred and forty form
submissions which means over thirteen
hundred and forty of you went on to a
random Google forum and answered show
names and guests in segments and I have
them here right now Nick if you have
liked
drums drum rolls and stuff that would be
great but not yet because here are the
honorable mentions that did not make the
top 10 these are the top ten show names
that you guys submitted that I can't use
or I'm not going to use but that made me
really left
honorable mention number one left goes
limp picks that was from Jared Hawk love
that to be honest might start using that
for my gambling segments throughout the
regular season by the way for everybody
out there the fantasy league has
continued continuing we're gonna do the
betting stuff it's gonna be awesome
another honorable mention name and left
ko that was from my now fiancé enum who
a lot of people want to come on the show
so that you can ask her questions I I
don't know I'm still deciding if I want
that to happen because she has some
scary information that I do not want to
have as leverage last one that's
honorable mention didn't make the top
ten from william martin the boulevard of
broken spleens sims isn't here
thus spleen jokes are gone so it is time
for the top ten show names that are not
able to make the final cut
nick if I can get some drumroll please
that would be amazing at number ten of
the show names that I can't use or that
I'm not going to the crunchy biscuit
with Adam left ko that one coming from
Henry meatloaf number nine the drew
brees appreciation society boy do we
love drew he's just so darn fantastic
that one's from Shane Nye Hill the
49-yard Club without him left go William
ezel I don't know if you guys are
celebrating forty nine or making fun of
me either way I'm not a fan can't do it
number seven to know I had this title
Indonesia's football king that was from
Sena mailing apparently left ko is
poppin in Indonesia number six
we're gonna start getting hateful from
be room left oh my god it's all gone
wrong yeah that one was tough yeah it's
going that way this one I really like
the ingenuity here from Jay wax 520 I
really like the ingenuity here from
Jayhawks 520 left and right and then it
has a note that says you need to get a
co-host whose last name is right so
great idea there from Jay wax 5:20 I
just have to find a co-host with the
last name right might have to call up
Nick number for Oren Thal and left Co
and then the subtitle is we got the
juice and this is from Tony who wants me
to just do a podcast with OJ Simpson
Orrin thaw and left go if that one that
one's definitely gonna work number three
very on brand here interrupted by left
co because truly whoever sits in that
chair will be interrupted that one was
from colpepper Eric I also like that
it's a play on you know there's the
company uninterrupted we're just gonna
be interrupted by left Co and by the way
during my interview with David deal
totally interrupted him a ton like tons
of it or it is back and I am
interrupting in a big way number two
this one is very well thought out left
coast extraordinary football knowledge
of enterprise podcast if you spell that
out lef koe pod very well done left goes
extraordinary football knowledge of
enterprise podcast really liked it
number two but then and that was from
Dan still so awesome job Dan but the
number one podcast named to replace Sims
and left Co that I'm not going to use by
laughed and thought it was funny
from PB bear not as fat as he sounds
awesome I should totally have a show
called
not as fat as he sounds which i think is
an you're saying that I have a fat voice
but that I'm not as fat as my voices fat
which is just
really really liked it so to all the
show titles out there I thank you for
all these submissions just for a tally
again of the thirteen hundred and fifty
this is where we stand right now and we
have to talk to bleach report and figure
it out but the number four number five
most one was the players podcast number
four was out of left Cofield number
three was somebody in left ko number two
was left ko and the homies but the run
away number one was the left ko show it
rhymes it sounds good and at first I was
kind of like man I don't really want it
to be called that but we're gonna see
we're gonna talk to people here bleacher
report I've kind of I kind of liked a
left go show we're gonna own it we're
gonna make it feel good if you're
curious the most voted on guests far and
away the most voted on guests that you
guys want is Patrick mahomes which was
interesting
number two was Aaron Rodgers number
three was Baker Mayfield number four was
Romo and number five was say Kwan a lot
of Pat McAfee's a lot of Gronk's Michael
and bar D who we just had on there was
in the top ten but a lot of good names
that I'm gonna give to our Booker's and
we're gonna see who they can get but
Patrick mahomes number one and the left
coast show was the number one so again
we're gonna have David deal on we do
whoa big offseason with David deal some
quotes and he talked about why his
fingers are all over the place
the Eagles Giants rivalry was really
good and I made him sign a contract to
hold up his bargain of the 33 percent by
the way this is also I'm not gonna
abandon my man Chris Sims because I love
him and I think that he does one thing
really well and we can all attest to
that which was scout the quarterbacks
well the thing with Sims not being here
anymore is I can listen to all of the
scouts I can listen to Daniel Jeremiah I
can listen to Matt Miller and Connor
Rodgers I can listen to all the stuff
that comes out but I would be crazy to
not listen to Sims so I listen to some
this morning and he's come out with his
top tier of quarterbacks he believes
that there's three above the rest my man
knows quarterbacks I'm not gonna not
listen but I'm also gonna make sure that
if he says something that I think is
great I'm gonna bring it to you guys out
of respect to him but also that's what
the [ __ ] show is and I'm not gonna
stop cursing and the signs down so who
knows how many more f-bombs I'm gonna
drop so first thing is he believes that
there's three quarterbacks above the
rest Kyler Murray Dwayne Haskins and
drew Locke out of Mizzou he believes is
the upper tier of quarterbacks what he
said about Cuyler Murray more electric
Runner than he thought maybe even more
than Lamar Jackson great decision-maker
and he can stripe it and he said that
when he started watching and that the
bots he thought he was gonna be a 16 to
32 pick and then he watched him and he
went he's a top 16 pick that's Sims own
calimary Dwayne Haskins said he has a
rocket arm big and strong can deliver
from weird angles and a great thrower
and while he only played one year where
he was at the end of the year was
immensely better than where he was at
the beginning of the year has a lot of
confidence in him drew Locke what's
really funny is Connor Rogers who were
gonna have on in two weeks from stick
the football podcast he over the years
cuz Connor has been here for like three
four years got very good at predicting
the quarterback that Sims was going to
fall in love with because we all know
the attributes Sims loves strong arm big
guy you know what Sims was when he was
coming out but he's a good appreciator
of talent that's why I respect it but he
predicted that Sims would love drew luck
here's what sim said about him
definitely a first rounder a special
thrower of the football make some
jaw-dropping throws he also makes some
dumb mistakes that you makes your jaw
drop as well and that's why he's not up
there with the top two and his argument
for why he makes some mistakes was when
you're on Missouri Missouri and your
team is less talented than everybody
else in the SEC you have to push the
envelope but that assumes as top-tier
and then in terms of combine
questions when asked about Cuyler Marie
sighs cuz we've heard the reports he's a
180-190 guy that apparently has bolt up
to 206 sim says I don't care if you're
206 now what would you be in week eight
you're probably gonna be back down to
that 195 I thought that was a great
point and in terms of Cuyler throwing we
actually talked about this with David
deal do you really want to see him out
there next to Haskins we all remember
that combine photo how much smaller he
looked that's my thing my left go take
right now on all the the takes I'm
hearing about the draft to everyone that
says the strategy of an NFL team should
be to trade down and get more picks
though or you think like every team
wants to accumulate more picks every
team that's drafting the the the
Cardinals need more picks the Giants
need more picks the Broncos need more
picks if your addition to the NFL
discussion is they should trade down and
get more picks of course like that's the
dumbest thing I've ever heard
please step away from the micro
microphone and give it to somebody
that's actually done analysis of the
players
I'm never gonna sit here and say that
I'm gonna talk to Miller I'm gonna talk
to Connor Rodgers I'm gonna bring in
draft experts and we're gonna figure out
what position a team needs the answer of
I'm gonna trade down and get more I
could say that for all 32 teams
seriously a little bit of news and notes
before we get to the homie David deal
Nick Foles while we were recording is
gonna be a free agent not gonna get
franchise tag I'm gonna be honest it
kind of upsets me a little bit cuz I was
hoping that they were gonna get value
for Nick Foles
that it wasn't gonna be this ceremonial
like send-off at the same point I'm not
that man at it because of what he did
and so I have the appreciation but also
the Jaguars have come out and said
they're very interested they were not
interested to trade I think they
probably had an idea if it's the Jaguars
Washington those feel like the two that
are most desperate again Washington on
the hook for Alex miss contract and they
don't
a guy I would imagine they're gonna be
looking in the giraffe to picking in the
teens but you know Nick Foles to the
Jaguars John D Filippo
and I don't want to give you all my
takes because with David we broke this
down a little bit more Andrew Whitworth
returning to the Rams I think that's a
huge story because if they were to lose
him
they'd have to they might lose Roger
Saffold to kiss a fields one of the big
free agent names in the interior line
market and as we've talked on this
podcast forever interior line play has
always been bad so to have a guy that's
great it would have left their offensive
line with a lot of holes
Whitworth coming back is huge for them
Quinn and Williams not doing the bench
press Conor Rogers and I from stick to
football we're talking about this
yesterday left go PR if you're already
known for being amazing at something
don't do it at the combine Lamar Jackson
didn't run the 40 because what if he had
is one bad run during that time we
already know he's fast
calimary don't run the 40 Quinn and
Williams you're known for being enormous
don't do the bench press but do the
other things and maybe impress us more
that's my left go PR do the combine
everyone's gonna say Muno do the cut
what are you afraid of do the combine
listen it's still a job interview we
still need to be smart we don't need to
show all of our cards if everyone knows
you're enormous Lee strong you don't
gotta do the bench press and go wow I
thought he would have done more than 25
do you don't need to do that
but run the 40 show everybody you're
faster do a three cone show your speed
and agility that's my left go PR for
guys in the combine Dallas Cowboys Randy
Gregory suspended for substance abuse
policy breaking that david irving under
evaluation for a possible suspension
it's time to move on every year we don't
know when they're gonna be there david
irving is truly one of the most athletic
and talented defensive lineman in the
NFL it's a shame what's happening I
don't know what's going on in their
lives and and and and really why this
keeps happening but they
need to in my mind break free and
support them any way they can off the
field but in terms of their depth chart
their depth chart looks amazing every
year
taco Charlton DeMarcus Lawrence it was
damn the defense of lime defensive end
that's been there forever and then those
two guys they'd have like five or six
guys and every year you look at their
depth chart and go they're deep and then
these guys keep making keep breaking
policy and getting suspended and then
they're left in the middle of the year
and they're a little shallow up front I
was thinking of Tyrone Crawford was the
guy I was thinking about but Malik
Collins they have some depth there but
you know David Irving's of free agents I
don't think he's going to coming back
they have Antoine woods in my opinion
it's time to move on one guy they're
they're not going to move on from Zeke
it's already come out Steven Jones
acting general manager son of Jerry
Jones has come out and said quote and
this is an unbelievable quote Zeke will
get a significant contract with Gurley
as the starting point Zeke will get a
significant contract with curly as the
starting point aka the todd gurley
contract in which he was like one of the
highest-paid running backs to the NFL
forty five million dollars he got is a
four-year extension fifty seven and a
half million in new money forty five
guaranteed and the issue that I have
with this they're also saying they want
to bring back to Marcus Lawrence they're
also saying that they want to give DAC a
new contract before he's actually up and
here they are pigeonholing themselves
into a monster contract with Zeke if
there's one guy that you can negotiate
with who had a suspension who's had some
off-the-field stuff who's had some
banged up injuries its Zeke but the
problem is is that the Jones family is
always obsessed with their players
liking them and I get it the GM is the
son of the owner every time I would
watch shows with them they're there
they're hanging out they want to be
friends they want them to like them so
much that they sabotage themselves in
contract situation
think about a few years ago they were in
cap hell all the money to roam oh all
the money to Witten all the money to DES
and they're always so shallow in depth
because they're always trying to give a
lot of money to their best guys on the
team and it leaves them with these huge
holes at the rest of their team there
were no backup linebackers for a while
there were no great backup offensive
linemen their wide receiving court was
among the most shallow in the NFL
they're gonna have a Morrie copper up
for a contract to Dallas just got
themselves out of contract hell but
because they're so obsessed with their
best players loving them and giving them
a little bit of extra juice they're
gonna put themselves right back in it
and they're gonna be that much more
reliant on their upper tier guys enough
of just me yeah suffered through enough
of that on Monday let's bring in the
2-time Super Bowl champion David deal he
is here the big man he walked in and I
got a little scared cuz I know we're
gonna have a debate about Eli in a
little bit that's fine but I'm excited
to have you here David deal how you
feeling I'm excellent I'm excellent I'm
all charged up ready to go got my
workout in this morning just like I'm
sure you did and I can't antagonize I
saw your ID and I was like this guy's
going like you're gonna play still no no
no that's all days a week how many days
a week I'll hit the weights three days a
week I'm on my peloton twice or three
times what do we benshan not nothing
over 275 I'm gonna do that anymore my
I've done enough after 20 years of
football jamming and punching honestly I
don't know I've never rubbed out I
haven't done weight like that in a long
time I don't need to I'm a washed-up
meathead now I know I don't have to push
the weight a collection neat linemen
love to hear the limits of your meat
headedness I know but you think about it
if I was still back in the 320 days I
wouldn't fit in the urinal right now and
the bleacher report bathroom no stalls I
know are tight I'm like jammed in there
now I'm like I wouldn't be able to go in
here if I was still willing to play no
because we have we have people that use
Reddit and they typically have slender
bodies before we get going I'm showing
this to the camera right now I have
constituted a contract the
33% contract I will read it out to you
okay just so you can understand the
homies now rise I David deal hereby
agreed to give my full 100% to fulfill
the 33 percent of this esteemed show I
will stand in accordance with left goes
33% and the homies 33% and I will focus
on not giving a hundred and ten percent
because that would throw off the math I
also promise not to ask about the
missing 1% otherwise I'll be publicly
derided as a narc so if you'd like to I
will sign that and everybody knows nick
offerman said there is not a possible
way to give 110 percent that maybe yes
yeah so I will give a hundred percent to
the 33 percent it's the way that it goes
yes signing it and we have his autograph
I will keep that on file but the number
66 thank you homies are given 33 and I'm
given 33 you got to bring in 233 and
that was my basketball number growing up
as a 33 Larry Bird Larry legend I didn't
play football until high school so for
me that was my background I played a you
with Quentin Richardson core Ligeti of
Chicago and that was my best background
1/2 going into football number one as a
kid I wasn't beat up like I play until
high school and then also playing
defensive basketball is the same exact
thing as playing left tackle on the end
of store think of Eli is the quarterback
is the hoop yeah offensive ends the guy
with the basketball staying around going
to the same power angle same cutoff
except for in football you get to punch
you get to jam it's look is the same
things I just said one of my left go P
ours right now is if you're an NFL
athlete especially someone to combine
you need to be putting clips of you
being awesome at basketball on line
because it's clearly spreading it's all
over Darwyn james dunking I'm watching
Myles Gary windmill and do crazy
I found that clip of quitting Nelson
doing a behind the back pass that people
love it and if I'm a guy in the combine
and let's say I have some questionable
character stuff put a clip of you doing
a windmill dunk because then the
reporters are gonna ask you about that
giving you less time to have to answer
tough question well everybody love ghost
videos out there everybody loves seeing
oh look at how explosively famous dance
it is gonna dwindle away anything of the
bad things that are gonna come about
with social media which we've seen over
the past alright so because you
here now you're giving your 33% we're
gonna do a little bit of whoa big
offseason which are stories that really
aren't that big of stories but they're
fun to talk about and I have my phone
here because it we're doing this in the
middle of press conferences at the
combine and a lot of news can break and
funny things can be said but this one
was Jon Gruden apparently whoa big
offseason he's such a grinder that last
season he hired a driver to drive his
SUV with multiple televisions while he
was watching all 22 film from his home
to the facility whoa it's a big
offseason yeah it's a big offseason but
I would say more whoa if I didn't hear
this already from Phillip Rivers going
back right worth this that's the thing
like colleagues I think guy and you're
coming out with it believe me we know
that you're crazy about yeah Chucky but
this has already been done Phillip
revived the Thunder for my dream is that
he actually lives five minutes from the
facility and he does it for that one
five I would be more impressed if he
lives really close to the facility then
further away because he needs to
maximize those four minutes he saw the
first five plays of blitz pickup and
he's like okay I'm good to go I'm good
I'm good
all right this is an amazing whoa big
offseason because it's so Bengals
a lawsuit has been filed by Bengals
season ticket holder Scott Poston
claiming he needs total reconstructive
surgery on his right shoulder after
slipping and falling in a substance used
to clean vomit while attending a Bengals
home game against the Steelers what's it
like that sawdust like crazy since it's
called devour absorbent powder I'm like
you I grew up where they would just
sprinkle some stuff over it and it had
that weird smell anyways you get up
early I'm throwing up already
apparently they would throw this on
there and you're supposed to clean it
off soon but they just kind of left it
and he slipped and fell and now he's
suing the team dude they got a month
around it because you know if you're
starting to get into that cold weather
and you didn't clean that hey you got a
case on your hands I don't see the Bon
Jovi slippery when wet tours right out
there I think my thing is there's no way
even if I was in the bathroom that I
would be able to be a witness because as
soon as I see someone slip and
faul I get so [ __ ] embarrassed that I
gotta leave like I like I nobody just
jelly Dhamma and it's not the vomit just
in general people slipping it Oh
like if I'm if I'm on the subway and
somebody likes like you know in the
sometimes the subway starts and people
fall yeah I got a turn away cuz imma
laugh in your [ __ ] face and I don't
want to be the same exactly I can't hide
that emotion no this one girl speaking
of which it was Atlantic going to the
Superbowl walking kind of like showing
off her new eggs yeah turf monster bites
it right in front of people
I literally bit my cheek enjoy wait cuz
she got up and she looked right at me I
had to turn back like yes because I'm
never gonna be the guy that helps you up
right now I'm just being very honest
unless you're an elderly person I have
to laugh like I expect people to laugh
at me like if I fall I'm getting up and
I'm making a joke because I don't want
anyone to be like bro you okay Lee know
when you've always been the biggest kid
do you think anybody in their life has
ever tried to help me up absolutely not
even on the football field knocking
somebody over getting knocked down
there was no helping hand there was no
reaching help I fall in I can't you
probably heard like big tree fall hard a
million times in your life absolutely
yeah and like you said nobody cares
you're the big guy you're good you're
fine you could wipe that right off damn
alright so I do have a few good quotes
that have come out really in the last
day or two new head coach of the Denver
Broncos Vic Fangio quote about Denver
the Sun does shine a lot they weren't
fibbing but they didn't tell me about my
skin drying up even my greasy Italian
skin I loved Vic Fangio he apparently
sounds like an Italian mobster and I
need to find audio of it but if he's
gonna be this character that can provide
a lot of quotes I'm very excited
absolutely he's an old school football
guy that's have you ever talked to him
absolutely I've interviewed with him
I've been on the opposite side of the
ball with him and the one thing that you
saw last year out of that Bears defense
it was like I was watching tape getting
ready for the NFC Championship game 2011
sure that Niners defense was so similar
they're adding more pieces to it we know
kalmec obviously did to them last year
but yeah he has those one-liners all the
time he's not gonna give you too much
information but he's gonna answer the
question and that's
he is funny they asked him when he got
Khalil Mack oh he's a beast where you
think he's good I'm willing to say that
I believe that they're definitely in the
top three that I believe Italian people
are some of the top three funniest
people in the world
I agree their one-liners every time I
meet someone that's like really italian
they crack me up all the time see I'm
Croatian so we're across - you love
Italy so it's the same type of
temperament but yeah Italians Greeks my
roommate from college his dad could be
one of the funniest guys when you
understand what he's saying it's
exciting
it could be one of the funniest guys
you'll ever sit down and meet with you
ready for this what does a deal from the
island of character yeah got it
Kirk come up rich yep you got it we're
gonna talk more Croatian because we have
a employee here his name's Gabe he's the
man for people that'll listen to
podcasts a long time he's stinky fingers
Gabe he is so Croatian that he told me
about like your tattoo on your arm and
he says that you're a legend for life
just for having the flag yeah it's so
funny about two years ago I get a call
it's during the summertime I'm look I'm
like Tony Gonzalez Hills dealer I'm in
var right now Croatia you didn't tell me
you're a legend I'm looking at a Jersey
and one of your cleats and his bar I'm
like get out of here the next day he
calls me FaceTime I'm like FaceTime why
my uncle sitting next to him in the bar
in Croatia what a small world how much
of your family is still in Croatia
my mother it was one that came over with
her family but I still have aunts and
uncles all over the coast you got a
coffin yeah I haven't been in two years
just because of busy during the summer
and doing things and then this year now
some wants my daughter being 12 I'm
definitely going back this summer so if
let's say we went to Croatia that would
be like a hero's March you think we're
like if you were like walking down the
street maybe a girl group a giant they
say the giant so that funny story it's
going back in 2012 after we won the
Super Bowl I'm with my best friend since
I was six Tommi Slav another Croatia
they we're running through split which
is the big major city and I kind of
turned to my side and I see his face
he's white and he's going stop stop
I have headphones on we're just I'm
training during the summer I turn around
and there's two police
this is running and it's like holding on
their guns I dropped my headphones off I
stand there like this well girl no group
of photo photograph I'm like all right
I'm like we got to do one thing they're
like what's that I'm like I gotta wear
the hat like okay
so I'm here with two Croatian police
officers and I got the hat on and I'm
standing next to him in the middle of
town but talk about one o'clock in the
afternoon just running do you see
there's an entire country that calls you
giant yeah girl oh yeah Wow we're not
like the nicknames now I mean I've
always been the biggest kid I used to
have to bring my birth certificate since
second grade on the basketball team
this kids not in third grade they used
to be yelling from the crowds I've
always been used to that I think it was
just so cool to go back from you know
when we won in 2007 for the first time
because at that time Bill Belichick's
Croatian as well so they're all two
Croatians in the Super Bowl for the
first time to start going back later and
seeing like giant shirts and places and
people pointing me out you know soccer
is number one and that will never change
basketball number two right Tina Raja
Toni Kukoc and great dudes but football
now they're all picking it up they've
got DIRECTV they're watching games ain't
no fantasy stuff and that's why when you
go over there and you when I was there
last year for the games in London any
time in Europe you can have a coffee a
cigarette and gamble on sports they're
all in that's so when you think about
now them moving over to London and
having more games they're Germans
Italians they know so much about the
game now that going back in oh seven
when we played there up against the
Dolphins the first time we were getting
booed for the victory formation we want
more football we're like this is the
greatest game in football the greatest
play in football right now kneeling yet
they didn't understand the rules going
back this year
this guy's got 1,500 yards last year
they knew everything about the game yeah
every NFL jersey was represented -
sitting there watching a family of four
or a husband wife a daughter and his son
come walkin and I'm looking at him dad's
wearing Raiders mom's were and Ravens
daughter was wearing uh what was she
wearing Titans and the son was wearing
Seahawks man so I'm like I am always
thought those families are plans I'm
like we're most of the NFL Hayes people
mostly these guys froze at Tannehill
Jersey we're from Germany I'm like
really they're like yeah we started
getting in
fell we picked our teams based upon the
jerseys these are our teams Wow so they
had like an inner rivalry and their
family just based upon the jerseys and
now they all follow this sport that's
quite you ever spoken with Belichick
about your Croatian ties yes yeah he's
been there before obviously is his
mother side and everything like that so
yeah that's part of it but when you talk
to Bill Belichick if you're not talking
about Volvos and lacrosse you're not
getting far with them that is yeah
Croatian no no you got it I was raised
around so I'm used to hearing it I can
understand everything I can speak broken
and kind of a street kind of slang yeah
but you could hear everything I can I
just hear it's like the most perfect
beaches in the world it's absolutely
incredible there's over 2,000 islands so
literally no one ever talks about that
area they everyone talks about Italy but
no one I feel like talks right it's just
invested over a billion dollars in
Croatia damn a minute first as a graph
it has over a billion dollars he's a big
financial investor they're building a
huge golf course out there actually were
Drazen Petrovic who's from on an island
because there's no golf courses out
there it's gonna be monumental so think
all those islands literally you bounce
the coast two days here catamaran two
days here and you just hop along
gorgeous well you've already you have
just invited me so that's right thank
you you're part of the fam other quote
Bruce Arians said he told his staff that
if they ever miss one of their kids
recital Zoar games that he would fire
them quote you can always make up that
time at work that is the most anti Bill
Belichick thing I've ever heard Tom
Coughlin
anybody I don't I don't know about that
look I I appreciate people caring about
their families I have heard stories
about Bruce Arians before that that's
kind of his personality there he'll take
off at 5:00 and go hang out with his
wife and that's great but the the
football guy in me is going mmm
can't handle that you're missing all
their recitals and see that's the thing
it is polar opposite of coach Coughlin
considering my old line coach Pat flurry
had a blow-up mattress in his office to
spend nights there because he was
grinding doing so much stuff but I feel
that's the way that you are as an
athlete it's a competitor like you don't
want to think like okay I got to leave a
five
this and maybe I didn't get everything
done look you wanted together but you're
like an [ __ ] for being upset to these
kids that guys are skipping kids soccer
playing 11 seasons in the NFL like
believe me it was tough not hear my
daughter's first words or seeing her
take her first steps that's difficult
but going to the Super Bowl 107 when she
was 2 and then going to it and winning
in 11 again when she's 6 and she has the
Lombardi Trophy and she understands that
makes it all worth it you're sacrificing
for their future and for them to not
only give them to sit financial things
that they need in life but to lead by
example the way you work your work ethic
those are things that I always had in my
family so I understand those things if
it was a time where you know you can get
away but if it's a Thursday and you're
breaking down 3rd down a game film
getting ready to go up against another
defensive coordinator like a Vic Fangio
you're not gonna get much sleep sitting
there looking at a daughter's recital
and you're sitting there all I didn't
get through this tape I've still got to
do this thing that's the toughest I
would I would argue that I would be
upset if I'm a coach now cuz I'm going
no Bruce I don't think you're
understanding I don't want to go to
Tommy's tuba lessons so please just let
me tell that to breakdown secondary
tendencies last quote this one though is
actually kind of serious Steve chyme
general manager of the Cardinals on if
Josh Rosen is the starting quarterback
for the Cardinals this season his quote
is he is right now third one why even
say right now you don't even why did you
start the controversy Steve all you have
to do is say he's our guy he's our
quarterback shot and that's it because
you don't have to give them for now
because sure enough here we are talking
about it is my thing would be to because
when you combine this with the fact that
Kliff Kingsbury has been rumored to be
obsessed with Kyler Murray and want him
to take him with the first pick and then
I'm going you know Josh Rosen has always
reminded me of who's that [ __ ] Eli
really not a great mobile guy super
smart dude in the pocket not the
strongest arm in the world but good
accurate throws great passes down the
seams and the Giants are sitting there
and they got to move on from Eli avenge
that I don't know this starts me
thinking like the Josh Rosen to the
Giants to
kind of work with Eli for that one year
gentleman came out today and said Eli's
our guy Shermer came out today and said
I want him to be our quarterback I'm
just kind of turned this into an Eli no
problem we could let first of all in
regards to the Arizona Cardinals and
Kliff Kingsbury if he is a hundred
percent than Kyler Murray is his guy you
as an organization better go out and
make that move to make sure that he is
and not have the feelings for Josh Rosen
he wasn't on the coaching staff that
wanted Josh Rosen he wasn't in charge of
who they scouted and who they wanted for
that roster and when you make a move
from a coach who got fired from a
college going to be an offensive
coordinator at another college and then
going in to now being the head coach of
an NFL team you better give him every
available asset that he needs because
not only is his job online but Steve cam
your job his job is aligned for a while
now with this being said if you don't go
out and get him this player that he
wants and that he believes can run a
system this could be the worst hire in
NFL history if it fails damn David
that's the facts though they have the
truth because if this is this guy like
he said a year ago and Kyle Emery
he could do everything and it's offense
if I had a number one overall pick take
them then if that is your firm a
hundred-percent belief and - it's in
them you better make that move and
better not have a single doubt about it
and and to go back to the Eli thing I'm
getting right into it no no no no of
course the thing I let me say this I
have an Eagles fan I'm gonna set all the
ground rules with you right now okay I'm
an Eagles fan all right we have kicked
your ass for the last 20 games before
that you guys kicked our ass when you
were there I am someone that will I
you can't give all the credit to the
quarterback and you can't give all the
blame it's 11 guys on offense yeah
offensive line super banged up a lot of
rotations the weapons though are there
now and I know that there were some
injuries yeah but I am someone that have
said on this program many times Eli
Manning is a problem at this point I
don't think that Eli scares you to go
deep I also think that Eli is a little
scared of his offensive line and I don't
think he's he's either holding the ball
too much at this point or he's thrown
away too quickly I as an Eagles fan love
that Eli is back I'm just stating that
for the record I'm happy to go back and
be with you but I but I also will say
because I went back and listened to you
on Francesa Noah there have been so many
changes in the offensive life yeah
there's only 12 combination so I don't
want to put everything at his feet but
your I don't think you're winning it
with Eli this year so I'm just gonna
state my truth go ahead and and you will
say this last year until the second half
to where they really had a diagnosis of
what type of roster they had what they
could implement offensive leave what
didn't work and then when first half
schedule was insanely enough it was time
and no one talked to me now but but to
even go back to that those were times
that Eli was seeing the rush not feeling
exactly he saw the Russian nose in it
how could you not when they're barreling
down the model of your a and B gaps with
blitzes and it's not getting picked up I
understand that there has to be a
transition to move on from Eli as a
quarterback as an athlete whether you
take yourself off of the shelf or it
gets stamped you have an expiration date
there's gonna be a time where you're
done and your career is is over I think
with the way that they have to
transition he's down for competition
they're gonna have to either draft or
get a free agent quarterback in here
that's not going to be a stopgap and
that is going to be the future of this
franchise but when you talk and when you
talk about a Haskins who's a one-year
starter I understand he has a coaching
Ryan day that's a great one that had all
that time in the NFL with Chip Kelly and
now under Ohio State running a pro-style
scheme but he barely got hit this past
season you never saw him really take on
those big hits that he has to bounce up
from and when you saw him in certain
games there wasn't that consistency that
you're looking out of like the four
quarterbacks that we had coming into
last year's draft so what does everybody
do they're trying to pump those guys up
to make that dress the same as it is but
it's not you knew that not coming into
this yeah so if Haskins is the guy after
they evaluate everything you all go in
he'll be even though he doesn't use the
word mentor he'll be the guy to help him
he'll be the guy to help groom him and
understand not only just based upon
talking but the preparation of what Eli
does breaking down film those are things
that you can't get
by just another coach right those are
things that you get from a veteran
player there are two types of veteran
quarterbacks in this league there's the
Alex Smith who Patrick mahomes who spoke
very openly about will sit there and
explain things and work with him and do
all that stuff and then there's the Eli
or the Big Ben which is watch my actions
yeah and you're just gonna learn that
way I don't have time because I need to
prepare for a week to of course and you
just watch and learn both can be
effective it just depends I think more
on the student then the teacher
sometimes because the student has to try
out the ego too and go why aren't you
helping me that's not how that if it
works no just [ __ ] learn no it's not
how it works and that's where those
lines were blurred and Green Bay between
McCarthy and Aaron Rodgers you could
tell that there wasn't the Bill
Belichick Tom Brady the Drew Brees the
Sean Payton then you could be great with
your coaching but when time comes to he
makes the decision and that's it there's
no second guessing here and that's what
separates people from being a part of a
team and the rest of the team he's one
of us he's treated the same way compared
to him well how come he's getting away
with it and I'm not that's what's taking
place in Pittsburgh right now but to
continue to go back to it
Eli even throughout the time with the
Davis Webb and the Jean Smith oh I'm not
a mentor that morning even though he was
gonna get benched he's sitting there in
the cafeteria talking with those two
going down coverages so even though you
see you're not to mentor that's the
quarterback coaches job that's not your
job your job is to lead by example and
show these guys what it takes day in and
day out and gaming cam game out to go
and they're prepared and ready to play
your best and bring out the best in
other guys you mentioned the greatest
young quarterback in the NFL the guy
that has binders full of notes and had
to get his own printer and maybe throws
too hard Davis Webb we we joke about
them all the time because there's been
no more pieces written about a guy
that's never really played well how did
that whole just being around the
organization how did the folklore of
Davis Webb even start well I think that
good of a worker well I I think the fact
that when you have a guy that's behind
Eli Manning that's taking the notes and
due diligence to do it that's great but
at the same time that potential better
me Pro
tifany out on the football field so a
lot of us so when you continued to hear
well what why not your address in Davis
web why well he's not right
he obviously wasn't ready to play and
you're not gonna throw him out there hit
like a fanbase and they're not gonna get
a fair evaluation if he lies running for
his life how is this guy gonna do it
without a running game and that's where
the Hail Mary between Ben McAdoo and
Jerry Reese came up
well Geno Smith can run for his life
better than those two guys maybe they'll
salvage our careers well that was us
something that you're not gonna bet on
in New York City considering you're
talking about who's gonna be the future
of your franchise well I watched a lot
of game film for the New York Jets and
you knew that wasn't Geno Smith you were
in the you were part of the news
recently because Landon Collins is
coming up on whether he's gonna be
franchised today getting a contract
there were some reports that came out
that he's cleaning out his locker he's
ready to move on then you come over the
top with a tweet and you go I was there
I was walking out with Lana that's not
what happened so what did happen where
does it stand right now with Landon I
got done after doing interviews with
college players and I actually
interviewed his brother who's a
defensive tackle for the University of
Miami who's coming out for the comp I
I'm walking through the locker room and
there's Lana what's going on he just
gets done doing his treatment on his
shoulder talk with him tell him I just
interviewed his brother everything goes
great I walk out he goes the other way
next thing you know I reports he's mad
he's disgruntled cleared out his locker
he walked out with everything I'm like
here to Louis Vuitton backpack and I
walked out with like and that's the
thing like I don't mind when you go out
there and you say this happened or that
happened but you better not just use a
source for it and if I'm gonna put
something out there which people said
well you haven't tweeted since the Super
Bowl I played and started over a decade
in the NFL on the offensive line I want
two Super Bowls I use my opinion based
upon facts things that I know that are
correct especially when you see them
firsthand compared to opinions and
sources I would never use it nor would I
ever have to where do you think the
Giants and Landon are now I think that
they're negotiating and tried to figure
it out you figure you still have the
franchise tag yeah has that option but
when you think about him you know he's a
better down in the box player when he
can be that room or be an eighth player
and
we help out in the run game but and part
of the blitz package but it's been
unfortunate it's been a revolving door
at the free safety position next to him
and in that secondary so when you look
at the overall darien thompson dorian
tom so that was two years ago he was on
a cowboy he was supposed to be like when
they Trent was at Boise State when they
took him everyone said it's aligned and
it just never until you saw him
completely missed tackles in the open
yeah take bad angles and compete over
the top was he those are things that
aren't good when you're you know let me
get your analysis really quickly of will
Hernandez well and some of the offensive
line because he was supposed to be a
come in right away and be a stud and
there's a growing curve to all this I
definitely I think that he got much
better especially in the second half of
this season he knew he was a road grader
but he needed to refine and work on his
tech need in the passing game which he
got so much better at because early on
you know when you you always think
you're either a gunslinger or you're a
boxer if you're a gunslinger and you're
shooting from the hip your hands it's
too late a defensive guy has his hands
inside and he's control knew as a boxer
your hands are always up and make sense
we fix that and also with that and being
the boxer not getting his head and
shoulder forwards you can mall and you
want to attack people your weights
off-balance pull and shoot you're
getting ripped right you have high hopes
I do I think that he's gonna be a very
good football player from the New York
Giants how many pieces do they have on
the old line that you have confidence in
going forward honestly right now too
so him and Nate's older and you think
cuz I know solder you go from the
Patriots where it's a six and a half
step try and get the ball out in three
seconds he had to probably change
without a doubt he had to change his
rate guard right tackle that's the big
question
obviously they talked about last year
jalapeño but he got hurt you know that
he's gonna come in and compete but the
right side of the offensive line
obviously JaJuan Brown came in last year
but he's a free agent they got to figure
out if they're gonna resign him yeah I
wouldn't sign him to a huge deal there's
a reason why the Rams let him go there's
always a reason to it and you saw him
when they weren't running the football
well exposed especially up against man
Fletcher Cox on the he's a Ladell see
he's the greatest these are guys like
him a reasons why I retired man seen
these guys that are that big that strong
guys
the league when you were there my last
year playing was 2013 and that was right
his second year I want to say I just
feel like right now him Chris Jones
there are McDonald's the Khalil max I
just don't feel like there were too many
of those guys like the super big and
fast guys I feel like this has been like
a recent creation now there's always
been special guy yeah but like I feel
like I see more of a Richard Seymour
compared to a get upfield - penetration
make them read write a much different
type of plan I feel like now we're
valuing the defensive tackle stars more
than we are the edge guys like I'm
sitting production and sex from a three
techniques inside how could you not a
selection women Williams like the giada
Alabama I'm seeing him going to and then
I'm seeing the Josh Allen's and those
speed outside guys going after him where
years ago that would have been
completely flipped see you know what I
can see part of that but at the same
time you're just throwing stuff out
there because of how deep the defensive
tackle draft because you know that's
what some place that if you are a
hundred percent committed to a Williams
you know you can pull that trigger but
if you're not and you feel like okay I
can get Allen I can get an edge rusher
and I can wait maybe til the second
round yes you could take that gamble
gamble and still get the return on
investment in the second ground because
it's so deep now when you're looking at
quarterbacks or skilled position guys
that's where it's really gonna be tricky
in this draft this is a deep offensive
line defensive tackle defense Avengers
so the Eagles just announced that Nick
Foles will be a free agent
they're not gonna franchise tag him and
then just good for good for him and good
for them to do well I I know that you I
want something back I know you got two
million back isn't that enough in return
from a very religious good man are they
gonna break that up and I think it'll
break am I getting like six dollars and
42 cents but the chef after just tweeted
that the Jaguars are the favorites for
Falls of course you know Coughlin is
that beef Olimpo is that other than ji
Filippo was his OC and they need a
quarterback because Blake bortles is
trash and all that stuff the Tom
Coughlin Nick Foles is that a marriage
like Murrow it would work 100% because
he knows what type of person and
character that Nick Foles is he knows
what type of leader he is in that
lacrima I'm
what other locker-room basically as a
shrine to the second-string quarterback
like in philadelphia yeah that's why you
knew regardless of what took place for
Carson Wentz to really take over that
football Nick Foles couldn't be on that
roster I think that fit is perfect and
when you do have a running back like
they have in for net and offensive line
even though they went through what five
yes size on injured reserves three of
the starters with Norwell being their
big signing they'll all be back healthy
they need weapons on the outside to help
out with that team to stretch the field
to help that defense I know if you have
a front seven and a secondary like that
all you have to do is control the time
of possession yeah keep these guys fresh
and they'll be able to unload I think
even more than being a good quarterback
and being a good decision maker I
believe and having spoke to some of
these Jaguars players the the fact that
they gave Blake bortles that two-year
deal for like forty million dollars for
thirty six whatever everybody was
shocked about it has to upset the locker
room yeah because they're going well why
did I get such less money and they're
also going we have all been good
soldiers yeah we have not gone in the
media and we have not said that our
defense is the reason we got to the AFC
Championship which everybody knows you
guys were afraid to throw the ball with
a minute left in the first half to
expand our lead and we let it slow just
kneel yes and we they they did pretty
yeah I mean here I develop they we have
also not alienated our teammate but now
you give a Super Bowl winning
quarterback MVP to that team it has to
give a confidence that's gonna be in
minicamp
you have to be in rookie camp that's
gonna be in training camp and they're
gonna look over and it's gonna make you
work harder like it has to it has to he
has thrived in the best moments that you
can as a player in the NFL the playoffs
and in the Super Bowl
what more can you ask for out of a
player like that compared to what you've
been getting over the last reverse Andy
Dalton and what I mean by is this that
is a great compares if Andy Dalton is
he's bizarro Andy dog if he throws 500
yards for the first eight weeks of the
year every single game and that's 4,000
yards in eight weeks we would all go
Nick Foles could throw four
hundred yards for the first eight weeks
and we can go would he get to the
playoffs though he's gonna ball and this
sit here and say that he didn't bring a
different life and energy to that Eagles
team after they got blown out in New
Orleans would be completely you know
what type of atmosphere that he brings
you know that he has trust in the
players he gets rid of the football
quickly and bringing him and takes him
was get rid of all that negative
attention that the defense got this past
year because they have somebody on that
side of the ball and replace they
believe alright so I want to play a
quick game
shout out to reddit NFL our NFL I still
subscribe that the people that comment
on reddit are better than the producers
at ESPN they come up with better topics
it's awesome and someone compiled a list
of audio of all the quarterbacks
Cadence's in the NFL and if I could
distinguish which players and I want I'm
gonna play it for you and I want to see
if you can figure out who it is so I
have five or six here and I'm gonna test
you here so Nick put up that audio and
the first one is this let's see if you
could figure out who this is that Brady
I so play at home so you say Brady it's
possible a correct answer is Andrew Luck
really yeah
take a listen captain Andrew oh yeah I
heard in the mouthpiece ass how can be
quarterbacks Cadence's like throw you
all the offensive line yeah like if
you're used to one guy his voice is
probably just in your head and they're
their rhythm and their tempo to it
that's the thing that you always hear
the tempo of a knock it's in and out of
the huddle and getting up there and
being crisp with it when you have a
quarterback that's new and all the
sudden he's making a different call
alert inaudible right at different times
and the cadence are pulling out that's
where you're like okay this could be
difficult especially when you're in big
third down alright this one's very
special to me so I hope you get it
[Applause]
no it's Aaron Rodgers really Aaron
Rodgers these are so small I know I
thought it was me longer but they're
it's I think this is a lot harder than I
thought it was gonna be all right so how
about this one that's he I heard the
white I heard the W that's he laughing
right away 100% so what I heard a split
second I heard it I heard the tone right
away what is it about it well first of
all they're going on to and then
secondly hold on why how did you get
that red white blue damn do they still
use that they change it out but they'll
give them a lot of teams through them
and ooh what other ones like that have
you used there's a lot you could do we
used to mess around we used to do a
bunch of different stuff but we would
mess with defenses we would say hey
disco disco disco disregard the audible
and that means like hey you're going
yeah we're not doing anything this is
all just smoke and mirrors until he
gives uh has there ever been a change or
something like that that was the most
effective that you remember like one
play where you guys talked about
something and we would call stuff that
we were like run play stuff to get play
action going all of a sudden you get
this defensive tackle going into the
dirt like anchor down you'd see
linebackers crawl up you have a tight
end peeling right over the tower you try
not to smile no I mean you're sitting
there punching a guy you're not smiling
no but I mean like before the play
you're seeing a team getting Oddy know
and you're like we got him no there was
a you have those you have your checks
your alerts your audibles those that are
the huddle but there's also times where
you just have to gamesmanship up front
you know the defensive linemen aren't
the smartest guys in the world but
they'll pick up after a while if you
keep using the same thing rich SOI Bert
he and I played together for over 40
games one time we're going in with the
past play he's like okay we're gonna
check to a play-action alike guy we
checked to the play-action he and I make
a fake run call sure enough we alert
what about that what's a fake run call
you just made like a like a deuce or
something like that well said to each
other yeah like doo doo doo so like
we're gonna double-team and move the
three techs and maybe the defense is
gonna pick
kneel down he thinks that we're gonna
double them and we're kick sin sure
enough we checked from a play-action
back to the run
oh no no who's been at the point of
attack tackle for like a 1-yard loss
we're like we got too smart for her own
good cuz you were trying to trick we're
trying to scam yeah has there ever been
a defender defensive lineman linebacker
safety that was so adept at picking up
your plays that had scared you well
London Fletcher was one of those guys
figure how long he plays shortly for the
Red Scare he was a student of the game
he made up for his size with his
intelligence and being able to pre-snap
stuff and he'd point things out and run
guard we got to check out of that one he
was one of those guys that the same
thing you hear Luke Kuechly Lukey Cleese
another one of those players that is so
instinctual that you see him talking to
the back end to the front and he runs
down plays that is strictly based upon
him understanding what you're doing on
the offensive side of the ball that's
that stuff's amazing when you see London
Fletcher played in over 250 a sec you
t'v games and figured twice a year of
the hence the Redskins yeah yeah I mean
it sooner or later he's gonna pick up
your tendencies alright especially at
that time he was playing for Greg
Williams so you better know what he's
doing this one I felt like was the only
cadence that I got on the first try
so I'll play it for you I'll give you a
hint
they have seen North fit your Andy
Dalton no this is Baker Mayfield this is
I just I feel like I've heard Baker
speak so much now that this is truly a
game where when you hear it they all
sound the same and then when you find
out what their names are you got exactly
alright it's just such a small snippet
has there ever been a quarterback that
you believe had the best cadence or the
best hard count not including Eli I
figure I mean I really didn't play for
any really on the other court figure my
rookie year my starting quarterback was
Kerry Collins okay my backup was Jason
Garrett Wow yeah what was he like he was
awesome
Garlock room
he was Jason Garrett's the best I have
met Jason and when you meet Jason it's
hard to make fun of Jason cuz he's so
such a good dude which explains the
clapping yes just trying to keep me very
positive but it's a funny the fake
enthusiasm gotta get it rolling and then
my third string quarterback was Jesse
Palmer that was my rookie here and it's
on your IG you guys still kick it yeah
and then my second year I had Kurt
Warner Aniela and that was it was that
the Jesse Palmer bachelor year
yeah the year before the year of out of
that go three go for it happened after
the season and considering we went four
and twelve they fired Jim fossil and a
season was an absolute mess I think that
it like kind of dwindled the way that
way but he definitely when we had spring
ball and it came back I don't want to
spend the rest of my life unless I spend
it with you we used to come up with
quotes and lines from it that's and give
it to him during spring ball and stuff
but I mean he's one of the best to do
speaking of IG I think I've deduced your
three favorite athletes of all time okay
tell me if I'm right okay Walter Payton
number one hands down I mean I'm wearing
your where the whole 70s I think
Muhammad Ali is in your top three it's
top top four okay and I feel like your
third is Ric Flair he's number two damn
number two so then Who am I missing
number Walter Payton number two Ric
Flair number four Muhammad Ali
number three Eli David deal Larry Bird
Larry Bird Thoreau writing growing up in
Chicago don't get me wrong I've got
Jordan see yeah greatest player ever
played but there was just that quiet
cool about Larry Bird yeah I mean
distorted him going in before the
three-point shootout okay who's coming
in second how could you not love that I
think I think Larry Bird shit-talking go
so it was so smooth oh yeah but I'm more
curious about the outward shit-talking
of Ric Flair how how did this start had
a nit grown up as a kid watching WWE
wrestling and WCW
my parents would go to work on Saturday
Saturday mornings I know what a camel
clutch feels like I know what a figure
four leglock feels like and I couldn't
say anything to my mom I'm the young
three boys my mom was still going to
work I please don't go to work mom she'd
be like oh this is so sweet
I couldn't tell her what was happening I
get it worse so growing up I just leave
time out so you had older brothers I
didn't eat the crap all the time I was
little lay outside go into the wall or
into the garage hit over a fence one
time on shoulder were they my oldest
brother is nine years and my middle
brother is seven oh so they really oh
yeah how much does that help you art in
the leg one time yeah what was that
story I beat him and I was yelling
talking trash dark comes from the back
hallway I get it in a leg up I mean did
it really make you that much tougher
without a doubt because then when you go
out there and I'm playing a you
basketball up against kids my own age
I'm like these guys are soft it's easy
I'm not getting thrown into the wall
here and so it made things so much
easier to transition because you're
always playing up so point up against
the older kid I have I've interviewed
Ric Flair twice I've met his what now
why yeah I think the thing that people
think about Ric Flair is his personality
when he was really in his prime with the
cockiness and stuff was over the top I
don't know if I've met a nicer person
never I'm telling you he's the kind of
guy where there will be 200 men grown
men lined up single file and whole leaf
50 voicemails whole record a hundred
tons one of them he'll get done and then
you'll see him in the back if you can go
in the back
yeah and he'll be exhausted but he'll
give every [ __ ] thing to beverage
it's incredible I've met him at the
Super Bowl for the first time I've
interviewed with him I've talked to him
over the phone but I this is the first
time I ever met him so I was I mean this
is like me meeting Jim Brown and Walter
Payton when I was a kid like these are
huge moments and yes these are guys who
watched as a kid and I'll never forget
how humble he was yeah there's somebody
coming around like the security Ric
Flair the person almost got clothesline
no no he's cool let him let me sign if
yeah he came all this way like people
don't normally do that especially if
you're Ric Flair and you get that
attention no matter where you go yeah
just to see him have that type of
personality I mean that's that's what
you want if you have a favorite Ric
Flair rant
mine is the silver spoon I love the
silver I was raised with
spoon I love this silver spoon and I
spent more money on liquor last year
than most but that's one of the greatest
ones yeah
can I do you have any weird fingers that
fourth one both fourth why are both of
your ring fingers jammed from playing in
the NFL 2011 vince wolf 4 went into his
left hand right now
vince wolf firk spins I go to twist them
this is the only thing stuck in his
shoulder pads the entire rest of the
season through the 2011 season I played
with the cast I had a broken hand he was
so big and the force of it my knuckle on
the side was powder I have like nine
screws I have metal plates in here like
dead is so underneath to pull it back
and basically he ripped my finger like
what would you compare the pain to I
don't know that one was probably the
worst pain I've ever felt I've had my
thumb ripped off oh yeah that one's a
little that was down to here lock with a
cast it's hard is there anything that's
an advantage well yeah because it's it's
hard it protects so you can hopefully
that's what I always thought is you
could just punch them but the same thing
though you have no grip you have no
control over the body and surface you're
not supposed to have crypt that's only
if you get caught and then what about
your other your right hands just once
again everything's like a game when
you're out there past setting so you're
not throwing your hands right at the
same time so like I used to call up
after my first coach the one arm piece
Toula de la Munoz Mouse McNally was my
coach my rookie year for the Giants he
coached munos all those times in tube
ankles and would show me these tapes so
flash it pull it back and yeah again see
if they swipe and one time I flashed I
pulled it back and I went to swipe again
and I drilled Oh rocker right in the top
of his helmet right in the crown
I had them taped together these like you
could see how my fingers are like [ __ ]
because you've taped them together so
much they start to mesh it ripped
through the tape like my finger was like
I'm to the side like I go to pull it
back people like you're crazy yeah I
have the nose I probably broke my nose
15:16 I feel like I would be thinking
two thoughts at the same time one I
can't let people see my pain cuz I don't
want them to think I wimp but also if I
overcome this I'm the baddest man
they're ever gonna see like were you did
you want people to see how [ __ ]
hardcore you were when some yeah not
during because the minute that you give
that defensive lineman that they're
hacking wait your hand are they really
oh yeah if you finish those games yeah I
finished the entire season I played from
November all the way through the
Superbowl in 2011 were people going
after the after they found out yeah I
had like a pair of Nike gloves that were
split like baseball gloves half white
half black and I taped that side just
black to try masking it they caught on
to it so they're hacking away right at
that hand best [ __ ] talkers you faced
ah well Strahan every day in practice
he was just funny about it he would like
make jokes and make funny stuff yeah but
how bad he'd be beating people on the
other side so he was great um I mean
there was a see more used to talk trash
yeah funny there's a lot of guys d-line
you guys were going up against practice
man with talkin audience
oh she's stray mathayus Kiwanuka jpp
like there was a pile of millions I love
saying look yeah he could play Sam he
could play defensive and he could play
will Matthias Kiwanuka is the perfect
example he compared them to like top
picks in the NBA where like it like
someone like an Andrew Wiggins the
Andrew Wiggins did not live up to being
the top pick but he's gonna have like a
15 year career because he's so frickin
athletic Darius Hayward may not great
for the eighth or ninth pick in the
draft
but he's in the [ __ ] NFL for 12 you
saw the Matthias Kiwanuka was going to
be in that draft the super edge rusher
out of Boston was so good but he had
this long career and was able to play
all these different positions because he
could play everything he was smart he
wouldn't he was selfless
he'd play D & E place Sam he played
everything that you wanted to play and
he was one of those guys that would be
pointing out things that the offenses
really all would be doing whoa yeah so
if you have a guy like that and you're
saying hey watch this watch this
it helps the rest of the defensive
linemen linebackers for what they're
looking for
what in on the David Tyree catch did you
block well I haven't like looked at it I
don't think any of us block well
otherwise it would be known as it
wouldn't be known as the play that I was
gonna say that you guys should be
applauded for performing so poorly on
that play because a few blocked the Eli
spin never happens now he probably just
hits David Tyree over the middle it's in
stride but instead because of your guys
inability to block
history was making yeah I listed better
than Snee on that play
well no Steve didn't have anybody it was
the left side we got a twist and a stunt
up front where Eli couldn't step up I
was kind of drifting and we just kept
blocking the funny thing is is that
people always ask what was it like when
he caught it we had no idea yeah where
were you facing when he called me we're
in the middle of a two minute drive to
win the Super Bowl
we just thought he'd caught it we had no
idea we're pushing we run to the ball
because we got to spike it and we
actually had a fourth and one after that
that we had to convert that nobody
remembers no so we just remember that
and then the Plaxico so Plaxico scores
the touchdown we get off to the
sidelines I'm sitting on the bench and
we're looking at the jumbotron that's
the first time you saw fans are going
crazy and I'm looking at sorbets he's
looking at me and we're like did he just
[ __ ] catch it off of his helmet that
was the first time we ever saw wow so
you guys were probably like the only
five people in the world that didn't see
that fit live yeah damn that's the
struggles of being an offensive laughs
it ended up getting done and we ended up
winning that game did you [ __ ] you're
still mad no I'm actually vindicated now
because the Eagles beat the Patriots so
it kind of puts us into a club as like
the three teams to beat Tom Brady we do
it twice you did you did and you still
got three to catch up to what is your
feeling towards the Eagles oh it was a
it's to me like if Nick Foles goes to
Washington I really are okay because I
finally on the Turnpike Cowboys like
Washington you haven't been relevant
like 2530 years you're not interest like
I don't yeah
but cowboys it's always been a hatred
just because I was raised to hate the
Cowboys Giants it's always been an older
brother younger brother thing like it's
always been like a brother yeah battle
where the games are always brutal
there's always freaking
injuries those are ones that you're
going in and regardless of what the
record is you know it's gonna be a fist
fight so we'll know right away so who
were that your biggest fist fights with
with the Eagle figure I mean we had
Trent Cole on that side of the hall I
mean at that time Simon that's a little
later you were Mike Patterson Mike
Patterson we had we had the freak on the
outside we have honor curse and Hugh
Douglas loved Eddie
who else did we out at the time you had
marks Emma no earlier as a linebacker
right Jeremiah Jeremiah Trotter Trotter
almost single terribly urges Trotter
almost killed Jeff Eagles that was
before they put the rule on when you
could hit the punter yeah literally
Trotter almost killed in Philadelphia
Jeff Eagles the hit he put on them do
you remember the dish Sean Jackson
they came never happened never happened
literally we what's your best moment if
you can the Eagles asked how much your
leave you here you here all week
don't kick it to him don't kick it to
him in that moment I'm sitting next to
Kevin booth he kicks it down the middle
of the field
Kevin booth just drops his helmet he
goes it's [ __ ] down we didn't even
watch it we knew it was gonna happen 21
points [ __ ] was crazy crazy that quick
what was your favorite moment of kicking
the Eagles ass I think in Philadelphia
when I almost pulled a fan out of the
stands Oh tell me that story
so I'm coming in and you know I laughs I
was chime in with him I'm like that's a
good one if they say something funny I
was chime in but it was the second year
after we played it was my second year
we're playing in a four in Philadelphia
and I'm walking out to my first year
playing right tackle and a fan grabs me
by my jersey in my back and he tells me
I hope you break your [ __ ] like just
like rich soy girl assed year damn we're
here that's your boy tibula fibula ankle
spiral fracture that's the only time
I've ever seen anybody and hurt anybody
in between a play screamed falling down
waving to the to the head trainer he
knew instantly so I turned around and I
snatched him and I got a good piece of
that starter jacket and I'm going to rip
and I see the hands in my security guard
pulls me a grill dinner so I Jam them
back in and having us apart is like you
could see the fear yeah
following here we go
back and I turn over towards that
section great to see you mr. deal
welcome to Delhi
oh yeah that's me that's one of my
greatest memories what's funny is is
something just happened last night where
a little kid Russell Westbrook's on the
court and Russell X walked by and the
little kid pushes him and Russell
Westbrook turned notice there was a kid
like took a deep breath and then like
leaned in and started talking to ya and
it's this thing where we need to explain
to kids very early but this isn't okay
no but but it was funny as so many the
comments were calm down it's just a kid
he'd even push the dart no do not touch
a human man that's the thing like if he
would have just been yelling I would
have been fine the fact that he grabbed
me physically your first instinct is to
defend yourself just turn around and
like I said I get a good video of like
the Jaguars defensive lineman almost
going in the stage that's where DeMarcus
Peters like going up there at the same
point is there a part of you that goes I
wonder what was said to provoke him
because there's no reason that he's just
going up and no there's certain guys
that you know that you're trying to push
the envelope with like I would read in
the BIOS when we were getting ready for
games it's involved in personal battles
that player I wouldn't sit there and I'd
have to say stuff too but like I always
did in my career minute the whistle
would blow I'd give an extra push a
little one just a little one and all of
a sudden it starts getting annoying and
all of a sudden what you're doing is I'm
gonna be on you for four plus quarters
I'm not giving up
yeah sure enough they're hitting it off
they're hitting it off the next thing
they're going to swing at you and
they're not focusing on what they're
supposed to be doing on the field
they're so pissed at you they just want
to fight you see if linebackers yawn
Adam because you're cashing them for
runs and zone schemes yeah they're just
so pissed off of you that's all they
focus on have you ever gotten like
really into somebody's head and aunt
Antoine Smith damn you thought that so
well easily cuz I played up against him
when he was in on he was on Houston I
played up against him when he was in
Arizona literally we snapped a huddle we
turn around it's our deal he's already
pointing me on my card I got this yeah
yeah this one's great thing you know
you've kind of won already so there's
there are fans that they know who did
who's gonna antagonize who's gonna talk
back ya know that type of stuff but at
the same time like you're not gonna go
up in the stands don't be soon enough to
do that but secondly how many times do
we hear like
fans Oh lawsuit he put water on me he
did like the guy at the Jaguars or the
Bills game yeah I can't put your hands
basically on people yet nothing's done
about ever we know we let fans because
they're just one of the 70,000 working
Joe's with a nine-to-five and I'm like
these guys are working right now and I
understand that and I have nothing but
the utmost respect I was a fan of this
game long before and you love the way
that stadiums are that people are crazy
because they're fully invested in
stadiums would not feel like that
yeah if it wasn't for the fans but at
the same time if you and I and we're in
a bar right now and you said something
to me and you just jammy like that you'd
be running you wouldn't be standing that
was going down egging it out when I when
I see you'd like doing a game or
something like that I always think
there's something about deal were like
if I was in Hoboken with them I would
feel very safe I just feel like if a bro
step to you when there's like this
happen when you're the biggest guy in
the room you can to do that and that's
like pick fights with you just because
you're big no no I mean that's a kid
they used to try to test me that's what
I mean
you're the biggest kid going around then
older guys are gonna try to test you I
got a bunch of fights as a kid I mean
it's south side of Chicago that's part
of growing up there you know but we're
not Pizza Pizza know what I mean like is
Chicago pizza pizza oh yeah did you take
your course ecology Chicago hands down
real I don't like the fold I'm not a
fold guy Wow I know the trying can't I
shake ah go one slice I would take
Chicago all day to you all day I shake
how big is the Croatian population
Chicago huge figure the three biggest
are New York Chicago and California just
a shout out to all the Croatian players
out there cuz I have a feeling you guys
all get down oh yeah my only other
question about you're heading into heads
was is there ever time where someone
really got into your head and you can
admit it now that Dan they kind of got
me that time no I don't think anybody
got into my head that way I think you
know when you're sitting there you're
playing your brookie year I think that's
when you're sitting there like the man
I'm 21 years old starting in the NFL my
first season like if you're looking at a
tiki barber at a tamati tumor and a
Kerry Collins in the Jeremy Shockey like
the magnitude of the situation hits you
pretty quick so I think more of them not
getting and getting into my head it was
more of me like digesting everything
that was going down and making sure that
I knew everything that was taking place
on a defense because it doesn't matter
at that point whether you're a rookie or
a fifth-year guy everybody else is
looking at you and relying on you to get
the job done no excuses no BS yeah that
was one of the biggest things for me I
think that would get more into my head
more than trying to get after other
people I was more focused on doing my
job my rookie would you rather have the
Earth Wind and Fire backfield of Jacob's
Bradshaw and ward or Seiko on Berkeley I
mean that's that's a tough one I know
there boys sake Juan is everything that
you can ever imagine that God put in a
body you tweeted he's like the most
prepared he is the most prepared player
and rookie I've seen in a very long time
mini camp this past year they had a
blocking assignment he was supposed to
have a blitz pickup he went the wrong
way they're like no you have to pick up
a he's like no I've read in the book
they're like no would you have he's like
I've read this last night to where they
flip back and whoever drew up the cards
drew it up wrong he was actually
blocking the right guy that it said on
the sheet and for the install for that
day yet somebody drew it up wrong and
not only did to know it but to have the
balls to stand up and say no I'm right
two other cones really you better really
know so that that's something that you
can't take away from him the type of
humble person that he is and what he
brings to other people like those are
things that you absolutely love about
him as a player but to be a part of a
group of five offensive line groups in
NFL history to block for 2,000 yards
backs yeah I gotta go with Earth Wind
and Fire it's a great name it's awesome
and also totally it was Ward when war
was at warder Branch I think I might
even Bradshaw when he jumped and spiked
the brad show that [ __ ] was the coolest
ah when he did that at the Christmas Eve
came up against the Jets yeah 11 after
running over a jet that was one of the
biggest celebration moments I think we
all had that's awesome yeah we were
called the little brother all year by by
Rex Ryan right [ __ ] that guy game over
we know that we have to win out
Christmas Eve the Empire State buildings
red white and blue four giant colors I
mean it doesn't get any better than that
um O'Dell where
like what can you share because this we
are the biggest Pro Odell show ever how
could you not even see better the name
of our fantasy team was Odell Rogers
okay just our different players but I'm
curious like what can you share about
Odell the worker that never gets out in
the media cuz it's either Odell the
dancer or Odell the trade bait like what
can you share with that he's sitting out
there before and after practice at least
getting a hundred balls from the jug
machine they have this pole that your
stand behind it's like a real thick pipe
so that you can't see anything and see
and they throw it hit and he's got to
turn sideways the opposite way with his
head to see the football because he
can't go the same way with his hands
he'll do that every time he catches the
ball he runs it through the end zone
like a touchdown the way that he handles
his rehab the way that he attacks his
conditioning those are things that you
can't deny and the thing about him after
GMO I don't know about you would sign
this guy in a minute because you know
that he can turn your football team and
your offense into one that can turn a 5
yard slant into a 60-yard touchdown
yeah thanks running back better it makes
the offensive line better makes the
quarterback better makes the other wide
receivers and tie the keys around the
Giants for the next two years I don't
know I think it's all boy yeah what's
going on why do you think we're in this
all the reason why is number one do you
know what type of return on investment
that you can get from them considering
the holes that not only they have on the
offensive side but more on the defensive
side of the ball for the Giants and
those are assets you can have for the
future and when you're tying up that
much money into one player it's hard to
disperse that and spread it around the
locker room to other areas of need even
though he is the best at his position
and when you think about that long term
I just think it's more based upon the
way that he carries himself and his
health that's the biggest thing that
people talk about oh this stuff off of
the field oh that's not what concerns me
I want a healthy teammate on the field
for 16 plus game right that's what
concerns me not him being a distraction
in a welcome because he's not not
because of the social media stuff
because everybody in the NFL does it I'm
more concerned about just having him out
on football field than anything else I
don't know where you are with the draft
I'm just starting it like um I like to
use the combine as
I'm just watching guys and I'm just
seeing who pops yeah and I know that
that's not gonna be my ultimate
designation of what I think but for
right now but firm right now there are
certain linebackers when I go Dan look
at his legs where I'm gonna look in
offensive lineman and go he's so much
more athletic and that's just my job he
has no leg who are just no matter what
position just your favorite players
entering this time of the year well I'm
excited to see Nick Bosa work out okay I
really am I mean yeah it's such a small
feels like miles Garrett where there's
the clear number one yeah everybody else
and it seems like Nick's that guy and I
just want to watch him more in his
workouts and what he does at the combine
because honestly when I sit there and I
look at him outside of power I actually
think he's better than his brother Wow
his hands his knees not as big as his
brothers leverage his ability because
he's lighter ease more athletics just
jump a whole little brother part
propaganda better because you're true
I'm excited to watch him I'm excited to
watch Haskins and the rest of these
quarterbacks row you know he's throwing
you know Luck's thrown our locks
throwing you know those guys are gonna
be throwing and the one thing that I
would suggest I know calimary wants to
go out there and a lot of it when you're
doing that stuff is confidence but could
you talk about and imagine little
brother around those guys who were 6 5 &
6 or how much smaller he's going to live
with - and Haskins at the at the Heisman
he looked like the little kid in me it's
kind of like I call it love co PR but if
you know he doesn't make a good throw
and then he goes back at Haskins it's
like towering over he don't look the
part
no thanks so much of this part of the
year is looking the part
everybody saw journals their life even
before he threw a football last year
walk out like ooh look at the size of
him compared to all the other
quarterbacks those are the little things
that you look at that Scouts and yeah
those first initial things that you
always see from players usually are the
things that show up time and time again
now that I think about it like Johnny
Manziel he just went out there and did
his own private workout and he did it in
the pads and that was all you really saw
if it was it yeah I guess yeah easy to
do that because you're running the green
Haskins is gonna I would say right now
that I think ahead of the combine
Haskins being out there looking the part
his biggest issue his immobility yeah
you don't show that there you know
you're just gonna roll out no offenders
you're not going full-speed it's not
your private workout massive arms got a
cannon yeah the only thing that you
worry about is this lack of experience
but if the case is like we said the New
York Giants are in love with them right
and they pick them because they're in
love and not that they're forcing the
issue you know that he'll be able to
learn things from Eli Manning from his
experience and he'll push Eli man to be
his best because if not you know Eli
knows that this is his last run I would
also say to the last quarterback that we
had with one year was Mitchell true
Biscay and he still went top three and I
think he is more of an athlete than a
quarterback while Haskins is more of a
quarterback than an athlete agreed and
everything that I'm hearing and I know
our guys won't stick to football Matt
Miller encounter Rodgers were saying
Matt's been here in at Ohio State his
board work is insane
like his ability to maintain plays and
that will come out this week yeah well
coaches will start talking about it
teams will start talking about it and if
you have massive arm great at the board
then even if he's just there for a year
you have the intelligence I can break it
down I mean that's what the Wonderlic is
for when you sit there and you look at
50 questions in 12 minutes basically it
breaks down to almost like what 14 and a
half seconds of prime it's just like
digesting czar like I don't I can forgot
my degree I got my masters all when I
know I'm an overreach I took the online
one which I don't know if it's the same
yeah I got a [ __ ] 41 did you really I
just held that over sims's head the
whole time I don't I don't know what I
had but either way like I said the whole
point of it is in that 50 questions in
12 minutes just quick what can you
process in that amount of time how
quickly can you do it it's not overly
hard it's just you thinking that process
of going from one to the other and the
other thing that you have to understand
is now you're gonna meet players and get
to actually meet them not things that
you see on film you're actually gonna
get to know the personality of this
player okay what did I say in film is
that true and accurate or is this person
who I'm seeing now this is the more
accurate yeah is he a leader is he not a
leader as he walk in with confidence or
is he just kind of waiting for us to run
- right those are things that you're
trying to digest just for me for my
viewing stuff
any ole einar D lineman that I should
keep my eye on this week obviously Cody
Ford the big guy out of Oklahoma he's
one that you have to want to watch out
for
obviously Jonah Williams out of Alabama
he's another big one I don't know what
they're gonna do with JaJuan Taylor he's
the offensive tackle out of Florida he's
injured but I'll tell you what I watch
film on him and he is a very good
offensive time yeah this is super early
but is there one offensive lineman that
you think has the most potential I could
see him or Dillard I could see Dillard
coming out of Washington State's gotta
up and making a move because he's an
athletic guy you could see him in his
feet right that he moves ah
but if JaJuan Taylor was the guy that I
was looking to watch him and which drill
should I care the most about I would say
mirror dodge back and forth and how they
kick sitting when they're pulling those
are the ones who do they have sink in
their hips is it an easy step or they
step in underneath themselves or they're
able to keep up with the rabbit and the
offensive line right are they backing up
or are they staying at the line those
are simple things that people like oh
well when we backed up behind he's
giving up ground on the old line and
he's not even given up touched those are
things you have to think about when
you're going through everything and the
things that I've always said to players
when they're going through this process
don't think that there's a time at the
combine where nobody's watching they're
already walking through they're gonna go
through the hotel what no matter what
you're doing you're hanging out with the
guys everybody's digesting everything
that you do because they're all looking
for that one thing he can't do my HAMP
do this he can't do that so my guy is
quitting Nelson like you like we we hung
out a little bit the Superbowl he's
awesome I've no Qi no McGlinchey I met
all those guys when they're rookies or
freshmen and I Notre Dame my old line
coach at Illinois from my five years was
Harry Houston who was at Notre Dame and
now Affairs so that's why I was and they
loved him he was it still to this day
the best oh my coach I could have ever
asked for
there's a reason why I was versatile and
able to play all the positions starting
my rookie year it's because I did it at
Illinois somebody get hurt he'd moved me
here me and Q thought he was going to
the Bears because of that yeah because
we thought Harry would draft him there
McGuinn see Ronnie Stanley Nelson I mean
you could keep going a guard that Martin
is brother Nick
yeah they're all unbelievable players
from your perspective there was a lot of
lofty praise given to Quinton Nelson
that he might be he was an all-pro as a
rookie which is crazy
there's nothing lofty about what he did
this year he deserved every son just
curious when you go into perspective of
the league you know when you're an
all-pro as a rookie and you're a top six
seven draft pick all of a sudden we're
gonna go wow he's on a track right now
yeah to be an all-time special do you
believe I believe I believe figure he
changed a complete dynamic of that
offensive line and he would never take
credit no and that's something you'd
never do as an offensive one they're
never gonna take credit for that
but hips his toughness his just
nastiness to get after people and want
to do that time and then time again
still coincidence they gave up the least
amount of sacks in the NFL and went from
worse to first with that group yeah now
you see the way that they're gonna
continue to move forward they get
another running back in there and
Indianapolis they fix everything and
address everything on the outside it's
gonna be a dangerous team moving forward
I can't believe I enjoy talking to a
giant not so bad for an eagle yourself
Thracian you're the man thank you you
too thanks for having me appreciate you
dude as you can tell deal is the man
really really enjoyed it I have no doubt
that he will be back again a guy that's
paying attention to the league a guy
that's passionate and willing to stand
up for what he believes and really
enjoyed it
speaking of passion speaking of the
Giants speaking of an absolute freakin
legend and it should be hall-of-famer if
you thought we were gonna keep talking
to Phil Simms on Wednesdays you're
absolutely crazy the big [ __ ] is here
to stay I was bothering this morning
Nick let's call that beautiful phone
number if Dirty Diana picks up that's
fine I need to talk to him about what
he's thinking for the draft and I'm
engaged now so are we still having the
wedding at Phil's house find that out
stop number you dialed is not in service
[Laughter]
that's incredible
Nick stop all right call us cell all
right call us al that's that is one of
the ultimate build something up can you
imagine if Phil changed his number
because he didn't want to do this show
that's incredible Chris made him change
his number that sandbaggin son of a
[ __ ] he thinks he can run from hello
hello well I guess there is something
wrong with our house phone I guess I
didn't pay the bill I don't know what
the heck government on there but now
amazing I just tried calling you guys in
my house phone didn't work what do you
know
see like that's the way this podcast is
so great because we even fix
telecommunications issues of course I
got somebody calling me but on the cell
phone my boob man you know the one thing
I love about the offseason what is that
Adam tell me the phone stops ringing hmm
yeah people all of a sudden don't need
anything from you I don't need anything
that's right yeah yeah I have a caller
but you know can you help me this no
well do hey so um how are you so I'm
feeling pretty well been traveling a lot
nothing no vacations just work and all
that stuff so it's all been good and I'm
bill well good I just I am watching the
TV and you know we're gonna have 40
quarterbacks trapped in the first round
because yeah I'm not sure they got their
franchise quarterback yet and uh oh you
know Tom Brady and it doesn't matter who
you are you might not be the guy just so
amazing I almost want to turn the TV off
already have you had a chance to dive
into these kids yet no I have not okay
so what are you one of them one second
yet except what I saw on TV during the
year and you know I haven't done it for
a lot of reasons what I need a break so
but I will I'll probably start Saturday
I'll probably do just guessing I'll
probably do four or five quarterbacks on
Saturday okay be my first and doing that
and I'll probably that doing about
usually it so I do 20 quarterbacks I
stop there how and then and then I'll
start doing the other players a little
yeah you're subtly for any of the reason
just to know them so when they come in
the league I just got a good feel for
who they are yeah who picked some of
what system they're gonna fit in so
what'd you think of that tip what'd you
think of the Giants coming out and
saying Eli's the guy next year
schirmer's excited to turn to my radio
said well they gather to see is he
long-term is he gonna play five more
years they got determined he's only got
played three more they need to draft the
guy to get him ready and I'm just going
oh my god please fire everybody holy
Christ
we're gonna draft him he might play two
more years we need to draft his get a
guy in waiting oh yeah I know lots of
guys in this day and age you know you
draft him high and they sit for three or
four years right don't haven't I haven't
I haven't salon I haven't seen one since
Rogers well yeah yeah and of course that
was an extreme set of circumstances and
you know what let's be honest to Aaron
Rodgers and his third year really the
talent really came out in training camp
preseason and practice where they went
wow we got to play this dude right and
so that was a very unique situation you
know what though it is kind of crazy
when you think about it that Patrick
mahomes didn't play almost his entire
first year to see what he is now it's
kind of crazy that we never saw when you
think about it well that just shows you
and of course that team without him
playing still what the plus I just kind
of shows you Andy Reid really knew what
he was doing yeah and you know he got
Alex Smith and knew that they could go
to the playoffs whatever he protected
Patrick mahomes and I kept going Wow you
know I it was hard for me even though
they what's the playoffs but I did watch
that last game that year yeah I remember
thinking oh my gosh this is you know it
was really pretty exciting to watch it
was against the Broncos I think and it
was not in great weather and he just
made some roses wow that is really
special and of course he exceeded all of
our expectations right I mean 200% to me
anybody in your Hall actually hear that
they're crazy yeah I mean we always knew
he had potential we always do
athleticism but MVP your first year with
5,000 yards and 50 touchdowns
that that would have seemed kind of like
a pipe dream so they'll be yeah there
used to be an old guy senator from the
Falcons played a long time Jeff man
milked and he was from University of
Kentucky and he played forever and they
draft the center every two or three
years and they'd go to him and go you
know this Senate a draft has got a lot
of potential and his great saying was
you know potentials a French word means
you ain't worth the crap yet and him and
I cleaned it up for you and so you know
that's that's an interesting thing you
know when I see old raps a guy for the
fuse no here we are dere car will and I
just saw them on TV two people sitting
there do you think the Raiders are gonna
draft their quarterback for the future
and start grooming oh yeah your car
let's see ease off 28 it's time to start
thinking ahead to the future you know
this name you never know what I happen
but just just a statement alone just
says wow this is crazy that is my
favorite thing about NFL Draft season is
in the beginning of the college football
season people go it's gonna be a weak
quarterback draft and then like very
before the NFL Draft they're like five
quarterbacks a rumor to go in the first
20 picks and you're like what like why
are we always rushing to take the guy
this year he's not there he's not there
yeah that's a good point and you know I
remember that last year buddy going oh
we got to get one this year because next
year's crop of what I write well how
does it look house is starting to look
now mmm and you know there's kids that
we haven't seen playing in college yet
we're gonna see him next year and we're
gonna go oh wow he's gonna be great he's
a franchise quarterback and all that
stuff and and so yeah yeah I I think I
did say with you guys early in a year
last year so let's let's pull back on
this is not going to be a good
quarterback draft class let's wait
cuz I thought it would be and then but
as a year played out I think there was a
little bit of minute and then I pull it
back the other way well I don't think
it's gonna turn out the way I thought
right but now here it is switching back
of course I didn't see Connor Murray
coming out of nowhere right yeah that
was big Andrew Luck who I was on all
year and knew about him and watched him
enough to know that you know he is
without question a first-round Talent
pair how much of a crapshoot the giraffe
tis in two different sports the NFL
draft two year or the draft with mahomes
Watson and true Biscay was supposed to
be a bad quarterback draft and all three
of those guys have ended up being either
good great or special the NBA draft this
the the one which was which was Lonzo
ball and Markel folds that was supposed
to be the draft that was stocked and
none of those guys are doing anything
and in the draft we just had for the NBA
was supposed to be awful Luca John chick
looks like a star Trey young looks and
credit the first six picks are all like
first team all-nba rookies and so every
year every year we and the funny thing
is is in the beginning of the year we
listen to the college guy the college
special guy and his advice on what its
gonna be and then when it comes to the
draft we don't listen to that guy
anymore
so why are we listening to them when the
season starts it's it's so funny that we
build up this narrative and it's not
always correct
well there's so many narratives the
driving crazy let's see number one is
well I worry about Mitchell it's risky
he only played one year well oh my god
yeah oh you got to start 32 games and
we're hearing that well Dewayne Haskins
now yeah no well yeah it's okay haven't
we put that to rest you know right be
quiet
don't say it don't don't show your your
whatever I don't want just don't do it
one year I I think I know who'd Wayne
Haskins is I saw it I don't see a need
to see another year to house a to
validate what I saw this year oh he
lucked into those 50 some touchdown
throws we've seen enough we know who he
is and everything and that's good
missile drew Biscay
I liked him coming out did I think that
was going to the second pick no but I
thought he might go in the top ten or 15
at worst and so you know let's think
about it what's the difference if you go
7 or 2 what it's a quarterback and you
know I'll remember this and all this
because there were so many for Biscay
haters you know most of them on TV
commenting because they know so much and
how do you look against the Philadelphia
Eagles in the playoff game
he was the best player in the field yeah
boom got that not Khalil Mack not
anybody else it wasn't Nick Foles it
wasn't Fletcher Cox it was Mitchell true
Biscay was the best player in the field
but when it comes to next year the
haters are gonna say what well you know
he just hasn't come through at the big
spot yet you know the primetime game the
playoffs you know all that bull and you
can go back to hating if you hate them
all you got to do is just wait because
sooner or later they're not gonna win
the game or something in this go see I
told you so so so I and here's my other
pet peeve right who else here let me go
of course well you know if you try Tyler
Murray you know you gotta be willing to
get a special offense Oh again please
shut up what is special what is what an
Oklahoma dude it's so different that
goes on the NFL oh if you draft Baker
Mayfield you got to create an offense
just for Baker because of this all let's
see he got under center with a lot of
two bags play-action passes shotgun to
the ball oh yeah that was really just
something I've never seen in the NFL so
you know this this thing that we got to
create an offense just for him is a big
myth and I don't know why everybody
keeps saying it like what what is it he
did at Oklahoma that is not done in the
NFL can I just think that they see a lot
of points and they see a lot of passing
and they assume it's different because
we love to say that the college offenses
are spread and wild when really that was
the NFL this year - for a lot of year it
was yeah and then as a year started
grinding down yes it is you know it's
you know what the NFL is I always say is
what it's the fastest adapting organism
in the world hmm
and these defenses and coaches the good
ones they started adapting to the
offenses and it kind of got a feel for
all the stuff moving along the players
over and over kept seeing the same stuff
because the league is a copycat league
yeah you know just a good example the
Chiefs ran a play where Kareem hunt went
up the scene and caught it was about a
75 yard touchdown pass against the
Patriots well the follow miss it the
first
the following week the Patriots ran it
and scored a touchdown again by the year
I think I counted 22 teams that put the
same play in and was running it in fact
the chief stranded twice in the
championship game and the running back
was wide open both times in my homes
against the Patriots got rushed one time
and the other time it was just too quick
to read it got all of it too quick and
there so but the league just keeps
copying so the players on the other side
get used to it and they keep adapting
and I thought the offense has really did
slow down towards the end of the year
speaking of adapting and evolving I got
some news for you Phil I have adapted
evolved and I am now engaged well
congratulations you know I did it last I
did it last week in Anguilla I popped
the question and now I'm a fiancee bro
Oh
were you shocked when she said yes I
felt I [ __ ] you I felt pretty confident
she was shot at which was good but I
guess I was shocked I think she was a
little she was surprised which was
awesome but I'm curious what kind of
advice you got for me well you know I'm
a smartass of course I always tell this
to all the people I said you know I
didn't know what happiness was until I
got married nobody goes oh I said now
it's too late a lot of wedding jokes
whatever but good for you Adam thank
repaying thanks really is she's a nice
girl and all that and and I'm glad she
said yes and so when is this do we have
a Michael we're gonna plan a wedding and
next year are we gonna like oh we don't
know yet we gonna wait six years before
we go what's going on you know I I did
ask you if there was any chance to maybe
have it at your place so I guess I kinda
have to work with your schedule if
that's possible well you could probably
have it here but I just want to tell you
just to give you a warning no I'm not
going to charge anything but doing a
wedding at your house or on the property
is really much more expensive than goes
when all the defense
stuff I'm in here what Oh because you
have to like rent all the tents and
stuff like that
yeah we gotta get something that to
air-condition the tent you gotta hit
light this oh you've done this before
cost of the generator yes I had my
daughter's wedding here on the property
and oh my gosh really oh I don't like
the sound of that people were telling me
things that's how much that generator
what call us I said there's no way I'm
not paying it let me call some people I
know
so everybody I called who was in the
business I thought I'm gonna get a great
deal
they actually quoted me higher Wow
people recharge to me that's like oh my
gosh now you're scaring me now I didn't
know here I was thinking I was beating
the system but really I was just putting
myself in a bad situation
yeah no it's trust me it's it's a big
headache
let's um wedding then you take care of
all the headaches for you and then just
you know walk out all right damn all
right man you know I you know it's funny
all these Wednesday's during the year we
talk most just about everyone I don't
know everyone but yeah darn near all
how's everything going my son you know
he's you know he abandons you or I know
whatever maybe y'all kicked him out I
don't know which typical typic he's a
slacker all right he wanted to yeah yeah
but it's good you know we got we had
David deal on today and he's telling me
war stories and all that stuff he came
in he was great and we're just gonna
we're gonna meet a lot of new people and
we're gonna keep talking ball and I'm
gonna keep calling you on Wednesday so
that once you do start studying that
film I can crack the code and enter this
you know it's really it's it's funny
it's you said it earlier oh it's not
gonna be you know everybody a
quarterback draft but now once again
always your which we are and that's all
that everybody is talking about non-stop
ever and they're measuring the words
well they set this word and yeah oh you
know that's not a hundred just so
they're you know it's almost like
politics
well what did you mean by is in duh I
didn't like the way they said oh dear
car is a franchise quarterback word they
didn't say for us what do you think said
tellers you know and and you know I've
learned this through the years and so
leave you and everybody you work with
that you know somebody on a team or a
coach or whatever and you know what
they're gonna do to you they're gonna
lie to you
mmm they're gonna lie because they want
you to spread the news and help spread
what they're trying to do and I can't
tell you how many good friends and
people that really can trust and they
like to majus cause it oh my god you
used me I feel used and you know they
just kind of laughed it go yeah man
sorry you know just just doing my
business here yeah so to take anybody's
word for anything if they're a coach or
an executive you got to be crazy write
down and listen to them well Phil I
promise I'll never use you except we'll
just talk on Wednesdays and Bailey's
appreciate you man oh hey Adam great to
talk to you sorry I got to look into
this phone you know I I tried to dial
you from my house phone and it said it's
out of my home it was out of my I
legitimately had about three seconds of
fear that I said oh no Phil Simms is
trying to avoid me and he maybe just
moved to get away from me so I'm glad
that's not I would never avoid you
you're too good of a man I really
appreciate you and listen listen I
really mean this congratulations on the
engagement thank you everything I wish
you well and can't wait for the wedding
whatever it comes and we saw your
athletic ability here last summer and
wiffle ball and everything now I want to
see what kind of dancer you are brother
I got some moves man oh yeah I do I
could know a rock with the best of them
yeah I got it alright alright good you
know you know I'm gonna kind of like
this don't tell me I want to show me
of course Oh we'll find out be my
pleasure thanks again buddy
all right buddy see Adam you have a
great day you too man and that is as
always being comparable the illustrious
the should be Hall of Famer Phil Simms
all
it's great to hear his voice but now I'm
damn it Nick I'm questioning whether or
not I want to have the wedding there I
don't I don't want to think about I want
to talk about football but roll that
beautiful music thank you so much to
Phil Simms for answering the calls when
his phone works thank you so much again
a David deal for dropping all the truth
bombs and thank you
to the homies who continued to give
their 33% like it's going out of style
I'll always give my 33 I know you'll
give your 33 do definitely gave his 33
today and he signed the contract to
prove it and Phil gave his 1% and
together a hundred percent of let's go
love y'all guys you guys are the [ __ ]
hit me up on social that the the all the
handles are still at Sims and left go as
we finalize this name will change but
you guys keep being awesome I'll keep
being awesome and go out and seize the
day cuz you're the [ __ ] and you deserve
it taillights you later ha la la la for
the lef koe holla holla holla holla damn
I was messed that up peace guys
you